Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a caller who always leaves very troll
ish questions, but there is actually some
meaty sort of substance here to talk about.
Let's play it, and then we'll discuss
Speaker 5: a real question
with real substance. Please.
Should Big Pharma. Pay for the education of
doctors since all of their doctors basically
pushed their pharmaceuticals right? I don't
see them pushing vitamins, minerals, nutrition,
good food, healthy food on processed
foods, ultra processed foods,
all that stuff is bad for you.
But they push pharmaceuticals.
Please ask that question.
Speaker 1: OK, so the caller is sort of
confused now. I am. I have to assume that what the
caller means by should pharmaceutical companies be
allowed to educate doctors? I assume what they
mean is that pharmaceutical companies send their
own reps to tell doctors about medications
and how they work, and it is sales. It is
essentially saying to doctors, Here's a great
medication for a conditions. Prescribe this.
I assume that that's what the caller is talking
about, and that entire infrastructure is very
problematic in the United States. We also
have in the United believe it's the U.S. and
New Zealand. I think the only two countries where
you can directly market medications to consumers
through media like you see ads on TV, ask your
doctor about this medication or that medication.
That's a major problem. Now that being said,
I think there are more and more doctors
who are talking, generally speaking, about
the importance of a good and healthy diet,
understanding just basics about nutrition,
undoing bad or flawed ideas. You know, I know
many doctors in many specialties who talk to me
about they try to have conversations with patients
that are much more general about lifestyle. And so
I don't think it's fair to say that doctors aren't
doing that. I do think that unfortunately,
particularly when you look at specialists,
specialists tend to be dealing with. Disease in
a way where you have to use the tools available
at the time, and so if someone comes in and they
have, you know, skin cancer or they already have
diabetes, of course you talk about lifestyle and
you should generally wear sunscreen when you go
out in the sun and you should eat a healthy diet
in order to improve the diabetes. But you also
have to deal with the situation as it is, and
sometimes that includes medication or surgical
interventions or whatever the case may be. But
I don't. I don't find this question to be. This
guy calls in and always says, I'm a troll and I'm
asking troubling questions. I think there's some
confusion in the caller, but I think that there is
no question that doctors are understanding these
kind of structural and systemic factors and the
importance of of a healthy lifestyle and all of
that at the at the tail end of it. There's this
very kind of pernicious thing where, you know.
There are conditions that are very much lifestyle
related, and if everybody did quote what they were
supposed to do, you would almost put some
specialists out of business because all of
a sudden you reduce the number of people with
that condition. I get that, I get that, I get
that a lot of money is made treating conditions
that are preventable in many cases, and that's a
conversation we've also had. But it's a little
bit different than what the caller is asking.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
More and more Democrats are getting anxious
about Joe Biden just getting the replacement on
the court for Stephen Breyer sooner than later.
And we're going to talk about that. There is a
Jewish student who was reprimanded for exposing
that students did a Nazi salute in class.
It wasn't the students doing the salute who
were reprimanded. It was the Jewish student who
blew the whistle. What? We'll talk about that
on today's bonus show. And also we're going
to talk about the organic cotton movement
and we will talk about what is
what is organic cotton mean.
And we're going to talk about scams
within that movement as well. Very
disturbing marketing thing that is going on all
of those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Don't miss it. Get instant access by signing
Unidentified: up at joining Pat Minkoff.